so Apple TV plus is officially out if
you guys aren't familiar it just
launched on November first Apple TV plus
is a bunch of original shows produced by
Apple which it's kind of cool that Apple
is now creating content but are the
current shows they have enough to
subscribe for $4.99 a month I think
that's the question that is on a lot of
people's minds and obviously this is
brand new
it's just launched obviously they don't
have the entire catalog of shows that
they eventually will have they say that
that will be launching some new shows
every month so some of the shows they
currently have right here so there's
Dickinson see with Jason Momoa I watched
the first episode I didn't get through
all of it because I really wanted to
watch the morning show so I started
watching that and it's Steve Carell
Jennifer Aniston and Reese Witherspoon
and I'll talk a little bit more about
that but I absolutely loved this show I
thought it was incredible Jennifer and
Reese and Steve their performances were
so amazing and I was looking forward to
seeing some of the reviews about what
other people thought and I was really
confused because some of the reviews
were not very good the people who are
writing I was like are we watching the
same show because the production value
the writing the editing just the whole
concept of it I think maybe it pushed
some people's buttons a little bit too
much and I got a little bit upset about
some of the content of them being so
brutally honest about what this industry
is light and how people are treated in
this industry I can go on a lot more
down that road when we're talking about
Apple TV so let me continue along from
the makers of a Sesame Street they have
the helpers the help note sorry the help
stirs and ghost writer Snoopy in space
for all mankind and they'll have some
more shows launching soon but ghost
writer I don't know if any of you guys
have watched this show when you were
younger but it was one of my favorite
shows I didn't even realize that this
was the show that they were gonna have
on here and I saw it I was like what
ghost
freaking writer I used to actually write
ghost writer notes in my notebooks and
thinking that goes right over right back
basically the premise in each episode is
these kids use this ghost writer who
helps them solve mysteries and crimes I
think that's probably not that much
it's a kids show do it maybe there needs
to be an adult version of ghostwriter
that is the thing I'd be a do it anyway
it was kind of cool watching that show
because I had a lot of nostalgia back
when I used to watch it when I was
younger and I think the biggest thing is
is there enough content for people to
subscribe but it is is when you buy an
Apple TV or a phone or a Mac you do get
a year free of this and I think right
now it is so extremely early but there
really isn't a lot of content I mean I
watched so much Apple TV this weekend
the morning show in particular so I
don't want to give any spoilers away but
this shows so powerful and even Jennifer
and races performance in this like
seeing those two together was so
incredible I mean being fans of all of
these actors separately but seeing them
together in such a powerful show was
just wow
right now there's only three episodes
that I watched the entire season in two
days I was able to get a preview of the
season and this show touches on so many
aspects of this industry it was crazy
though watching this and I think for a
lot of people it's going to be extremely
triggering because there's a lot of
stuff and they really do not hold back
it is incredibly honest incredibly
brutal and something else that I really
like is that they do show both
perspectives they also show the women in
those situations they also show the
effect of Steve Carell and him trying to
redeem himself and just it put me in a
mood after I was done watching it mostly
because of the issues that it brought up
a lot of issues that are not talked
about very frequently it's just so crazy
because it's definitely not the show
that I originally first thought but it
was going to be I thought it was gonna
be a comedy I thought it was gonna be
funny and light-hearted but it was
honestly anything but that it was deep
it was dark it was moving it was
emotional I mean I definitely found
myself almost in tears and some points a
lot of the parts that I mostly was able
to identify with is witnessing I guess
Rhys and Jennifer and seeing them have
to go on camera
when basically their entire lives around
them are completely crumbling and it's
something that the audience doesn't see
and it was really hard to watch knowing
I have been in very similar situations
where I've had to go on camera I've had
to go on live television just finding
out some of the possibly worse news you
could ever find out and then you have to
just turn on a dime and be on and be
present and be on camera and do your job
and get through and that is just some
emotional turmoil it is just God it just
rips your freaking heart out like you
have to completely just turn yourself
into a character and just throw all of
your emotions out the window like I
can't even explain it one example that I
guess I feel sort of comfortable talking
about I mean there's been so many
situations where this has happened where
you guys have probably seen me be myself
but in my mind I am somewhere else like
absolutely somewhere else I had to do a
live show once after finding out someone
had passed away and was very close to me
and it was just so traumatic mostly just
because this person who had passed away
it was someone also in the media's of
having to see people talk about this
person and not know that I knew them and
had a relationship with this person and
just seeing the media just tear them
apart and just oh my god it was honestly
one of the worst things that I've had to
experience just because I had to be on
camera and inside I'm just being ripped
apart knowing that I was in a completely
different country than where this person
was the were their friends were I
no one to talk to about it because I was
around strangers I was around people
that I didn't really know very well and
then I had to go and be live on a show
for an entire day straight not just the
day it was that entire weekend I had to
do this show so trying to process your
emotions but yet try to be on camera it
was just oh my god and then just
everywhere I look in the news on Twitter
absolutely everywhere it was just being
shove it in my face and I had no way to
even just process it I just had to do my
job and then go home and hopefully try
to process it it was actually very hard
because even then I was at home still
processing it alone and not really
sharing that on the internet or anything
but there's just so many instances of
that that has happened over the course
of the years that I've been creating
content in the past couple of years I
think even for me and my sister and my
family has been some of the toughest
that I think we've ever had to deal with
you know life has to go on and how do
you deal with that yet try to continue
to create content and and continue to
have this career yet also try to
maintain your sanity and deal with your
emotions and deal with these things and
not let it affect your job I don't have
an answer for you it's never easy I
don't know this is a long-winded kind of
story even though supposed to be talking
about Apple TV but this show really did
have an impact on me and I think that
these reviews that people are saying
about it or I don't think they're
accurate and I think a lot of people
maybe coming from a place that say they
don't like the show because maybe they
don't like the content of it and the
honesty and just the brutal emotional
rollercoaster it's going to put you
through with all that being said I think
Apple TV Plus is gonna be interesting I
think that it definitely needs more
content obviously if you do have a
subscription right now for free there is
a 7 day trial so with that you know
you're able to actually check out some
of the shows do some binge watching I
think it's gonna be interesting to see
where this goes because they need more
they need to have access to higher
production shows I think $4.99 is still
a pretty good price if they start adding
more content monthly I'm excited to see
some more of the shows that they have
come out I would love to know from you
guys what subscriptions do you guys
already have because I feel like I have
Spotify of Apple music I got Apple news
I know about Arcade now with Apple TV
and the Netflix and Hulu I mean at this
point I don't want to do the Matt I
don't even want to think about it but
what is cool is you like I have Apple TV
on my iPod Apple TV on my tiny little
pink iPod and of course I also have it
on my iPhone and of course if you've
updated your Mac's to Catalina you also
have the TV app and I also did a video
about my Samsung TV it was one of the
ones that has Apple TV already
integrated into it so now Apple TV is
available on so many more devices this
is really exciting because there's so
much great content there and to be able
to have it across multiple platforms is
amazing so that's sort of my first
initial thoughts of Apple TV I love the
morning show I cannot stress enough how
amazing Reiss and Jennifer were in this
show Steve Carell was also incredible
because he's playing a really tough
character I don't know what these
reviews are saying but I personally
enjoyed it I related so much with it and
it definitely triggered a few things in
me that just made me remember a lot of
things and how difficult life is not
only just going through your day-to-day
but like being on camera and being a
personality because a lot of times you
have to carry the weight of so much on
your shoulders and yet you have to
somehow figure out how to not let that
show that's not just something that I
think us on camera people will have to
deal with you guys have to deal with it
too you still have to go to work you
have to show up you have to be there and
somehow deal with the tragedies that
life throws at you I guess this video
turned weird I'm sorry but yeah that
show was just it was really something
and I'm looking forward to seeing what
you guys think of it and I can't wait
for them to have all the episodes out so
you can just really go through and just
watch it and just see it from start to
finish so I'm gonna go I'll see you guys
later
and that's a lot
for you today Apple TV
[Music]